Emma said hey back projection cue music
an accent Hollywood legends mr. Stan
Laurel of Kali Pahadi arrived in Britain
today as they embarked on a national
tour we're doing this well while waiting
for this new picture to come together
I'm gonna make sure that this tour gets
off the right foot this Eiffel Tower
it's amazing that you two are still
going strong still using the same old
material yeah such a wonderful reception
isn't it Eden it's okay to double X for
the price of one for the everything last
night I guess if you just don't want to
see long hardly anymore
it's even pushing you a little too early
you know Stan you could have said
goodbye Oliver a long time ago we had a
good thing going but you had this big
chip on your shoulder
cuz I did a picture with someone else I
couldn't sleep the days when they told
me what you did you're just a lazy ass
got lucky because you met me lucky to
spend my life with a man who hides
behind his typewriter you betrayed me
betrayed our friendship yeah Hollow
you cannot go onstage again in your
condition I love you but I won't stand
by and watch this nut eat or put you in
a wooden love
I should never had us take this tour I
love it vida
[Music]
you're not leaving on your stand the
show must go on
[Music]
when you watch our movies that was just
the two of us each other in their regret
our ears
you shouldn't read reverie any Laurel
mr. Oliver hot
I'll miss us when we're gone shall we
you